[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode the
Kos and you know what's going on engage
you have one of DC's finest probably the
main reason that got me back into
reading DC comic books you came here for
the main man Lobo you see them Premium
Format sideshows first Lobo
now recently there has been a Lobo craze
you have prime one doing a little Bowl I
believe you have XM doing a Lobo
you also have sideshow doing another
Lobo which I might buy now this week was
really hard because when I ended off on
the last video I said I'm gonna show you
someone who might take over the world so
I had idea of that character going
forward
then Lobo just kept talking to me so
when I started the first video global
package arrived another outstanding
character and that character is in our
budget line you know a lot of these
statues cost a ton of money and these
statues are premium you know this statue
I believe he goes for when he first came
out was probably like $6.99 $7.99 and
then when it hits eBay the prices rise
so he's probably going for 1200 now and
and that might be out of the price range
and also he's a pretty pretty big statue
as you can see so you will go to loads
of gaming net to get the dimensions of
the statute see if the statue actually
fits your decor in your space
accommodations form but the statue that
came in the mill that fits our budget
line and in our budget line those
statues go anywhere from 60 to 120 to
200 dollars and those are affordable
statues and they also fit every and any
space allotted so that way you guys
don't feel that all of my statues are
some you know super costly statues
remember your collectible situation is
predicated on your love and I'm just
saying sharing my love with you so
without further ado I give you DC's Lobo
now at this time when Lobo is being
reimagined because the first time Lobo
came through I remember his clothes
looking weird and he had weird powers
like his powers was every drop of blood
it would be another Lobo like he will
multiply like he's the multiple man and
he killed off all the people on his
planet he's the last of his kind
he was sadistic and I think DC noticed
the lure of Wolverine the antihero and
then Punisher trying to figure out how
we can get characters that are that cold
and make a mainstream make them you know
to sell books you know to get to
interest in so they reimagine Lobo and
I'm so on board with to reimagine of
them because he had this leather jacket
yes this dog yes guns like The Punisher
yes you know the face shoe like
Wolverine and he's strong like Superman
and they send them up against DC's you
know big bag Superman you know take out
Superman but mobile has absolutely no
fair he's the main man he's bad as
Wolverine he got guns to rival Punisher
and he's the strongest Superman
there's no fear and in rise a motorcycle
and he's fantastic so they have many
iterations of the character I got told
you the first iteration where I didn't
like the clothes then they have the
second one I really love dis Lobo and
then they have this
we're not even address that level
doesn't how to even load well let's
let's let's keep it 100% real this is
the main man this is the dude that got
you so here we have the Premium Format
statue of sideshow Lobo and comes with
two different head scopes this is not
the exclusive edition the school edition
has him holding the ghost riders head
you see I forgot to add that to it they
took like all the best badass characters
from Marvel which is the ghost rider
because he rides a bike which is the
guns of the Punisher and that whole
rough and toughness of Wolverine you see
the hook so the exclusive comes with him
with the Ghost Rider head you see the
cigar that he has in his mouth but this
one has the two heads and I'm the one
with the dreads that you can see here
then they have the more classic ghost
ride ahead put the hair back
and baring the teeth what you can see
here I love how the hair lays on his
shoulders and it's part of the
mixed-media because this statue has
mixed media it's leather
the jacket is real leather the pants is
real leather it's put on to a poly stone
statue and the chain is real chain as
the wrapping around the arm and it hangs
and it's just such a well done statue
the level of detail and the muscles and
the colors I think sideshow knocked it
out the park with this the size fits any
Vesta that you can get from Ikea and the
door closed so it's a very good statute
if you look at the base the base
indicates like his bike so you can see
the exhaust mufflers on the side of the
base and the front of his bike has a
sculpt and you know he's right there I
just feel that Lobo represents all of
what's really good with the anti-hero
concept
[Music]
he's a bounty hunter he's the baddest
bounty hunter in the galaxy and no
matter his prey lo will always come
through
hey we got through this one even though
I really wanted to get inside that box
that's right so tune in next week when
we have another exciting episode of Kos
also I would like for you guys if you
didn't do so already light follow and
subscribe also go to Lords of gaben
nation where you can get all the
dimensions of this character and you can
look at past episodes of Kos also
because Lords are giving Garnett has all
the new information on games sports
opinion pieces and that ludus shooter
news with the last word with lower
kognito and Eve on ttis stick around
when you can see this statue in all its
glory and look at the nice pictures that
are up thank you again
I appreciate you guys every week Oh last
week in the comments somebody you want
to lead a show more of my collection
well this is to answer your question on
why you don't see more of that if you
look at earlier videos you would see
more of my collection what I decided is
when I'm finished my room because I have
multiple forms of statutes that I will
do a tour and it will always be a
end-of-the-year tour so that way you can
just get a walk through and see all the
statutes that you see throughout the
year and maybe you might see some
statues a minute that I didn't even put
up yet cause I always have new previews
and pre-orders of new statues coming and
displaying as a collector you know that
some of your statues are for sale so
some statues may leave and new statues
come in I have a ton of new statues that
I have coming and a lot that's here and
I have a lot that I haven't shown so I
won't give it away what's showing you my
collection ahead of time tune in next
week when I give me what came in that
box
this is Kos stick around so you can see
the videos of this statute Lobo the main
man and all its glory
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]